le jour 4 avec lui c'est parti l'ascb la
tête
[Musique]
voilà donc c'est la septième séance sur
les six prévus au départ donc à partir
d'aujourd'hui je passe officiellement
encore forfait ce que je propose c'est
elle est directement comme ça ce sera
fait et puis après je reviens et on
discute de tout ça d'accord j'espère que
cette fois ça se passait mieux que la
dernière fois
je vous dis ça après bravo michel bazire
c'est votre problème
cette chose en son temps
ouais ouais
[Musique]
oh
voilà c'est le mot que vous avez vu ça
fait encore un petit peu mal un petit
peu très mal même mais je suis resté
extrêmement dignes et c'est faux je
rentre chez moi et puis en débrayant peu
tout ça voilà c'est fini
alors petit rituel comme d'habitude
maintenant ça c'est la photo du tatouage
juste avant la séance 1 donc bah comme
vous voyez depuis deux mois ça n'a pas
bougé
et ça c'est la photo du tatouage juste
après la séance quand j'ai retiré le
pansement
c'est encore bien bien gonflés bien joli
hein
alors quand vous avez vu j'ai encore eu
bien mal hein c'est j'ai même
l'impression que c'est de plus en plus
douloureux en fait si ça marchait pas je
crois que c'est vraiment un truc que je
supporterai son problème mais bon là on
va pas se mentir ça marche pas debout
donc pour faire un petit peu le point je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez la
dernière fois le médecin m'avait dit que
il avait l'impression que l'encré hd
c'est de moins en moins bien au laser
donc je vais me reposer la question
aujourd'hui tu ai demandé si c'était
toujours le cas mais dit oui
effectivement ça ne fonctionne pas bien
voire pas du tout donc j'ai demandé si
c'était à son avis un problème de
quantité d'encre ou un problème de
qualité d'encre donc pour lui c'est très
clairement la qualité de l'antre m'a dit
c'est une enquête trop coriace il a
employé le mot coriace en 2018 alors du
coup ben j'ai recontacté hama et julien
les deux tatoueurs du studio keller qui
m'avait fait le tatouage ya maintenant
plus d'un an et je leur ai demandé
quelle encre il avait utilisé donc ils
m'ont envoyé les références et cette
encre là d'après eux c'est l'encré noire
la plus couramment utilisée par les
tatoueurs ce que m'a confirmé une pote à
moi qui est tatoué ce qui utilise aussi
cette entre la haie qui m'a dit c'est
vraiment la base quoi je me dis si son
laser aux gars ils marchent pas mal pas
on va pas se mentir si lazare marche pas
sur lancre la plus courante est sur du
noir en plus c'est à dire la couleur qui
est censé être la moins difficile à
faire partir ben du coup caisse comment
ça se passe je l'air ça marche sur quoi
et puis un autre truc qui m'a un peu
chagriné mais ça c'était la semaine
dernière c'est un truc a dit un teint le
tatoueur pas le
le journaliste belge en papier peint
donc le tatoueur qui disait sur europe 1
bah il disait ça écoutez si c'est un
truc qui a été fait par un vrai
professionnel bonne chance pour le faire
retirer mais bon laser voilà n'est pas
très pas très encourageant
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire j'ai
rediscuter avec différentes personnes et
notamment ma pote tatoueuse et je pense
que ce coup là je vais considérer à 90%
que c'était mon dernier rendez vous dans
ce centre de la vierge par prix de
rendez-vous d'ailleurs je me laisse un
peu de temps de réfléchir je pense que
je vais vraiment tester un laser de
dernière génération un truc un peu plus
puissants voilà l'idée de départ c'était
de tester le laser basit le truc sur
lequel on tombe le plus facilement quand
on cherche retirer un tatouage au laser
sur paris sur google donc du coup j'ai
fait l'expérience avec un tatoueur pro
lancre la plus courante un motif assez
classique quoi un portrait en tracé donc
la technique de laser la plus facilement
trouvable le truc de base j'ai pas envie
de continuer encore un an deux ans comme
ça vraiment eu les résultats que j'ai là
je vais passer à la vitesse supérieure
je pense
il ya des nouveaux lasers tant mieux
parce que ça sauve la vie de certaines
personnes qui ont vraiment fait
n'importe quoi
non parce que là on va pas se voiler la
face ça bouge pas du trou donc on doit
d'ici quelques semaines puisqu'il faut
attendre le temps que les cellules
fassler leur boulot mais la voilà à quoi
ça ressemble le lendemain de la séance
de laser là et la voilà à quoi ça
ressemble le surlendemain donc deux
jours
deux jours après ce n'est pas probant
voilà j'ai donc employer le terme
probant fun fact c'était peut-être la
dernière fois que je voyais
le médecin en question il a réalisé
aujourd'hui que c'était pas le portrait
du capitaine haddock qu'il était en
train de décider de me faire partir du
cul depuis plus d'un an
voilà il a compris aujourd'hui même que
c'était cyril hanouna en fait voilà déjà
mais trop tard avait un autre truc aussi
vous avez été très très très très
nombreuses et très très nombreux à
m'envoyer plein d'articles sur cette
équipe de chercheurs marseillais qui
aura fait une découverte sur la façon
dont l'encré des tatouages reste dans la
peau et donc potentiellement sur face à
ouvrirait potentiellement la voie à de
nouvelles techniques de détatouage donc
vous m'avez vraiment voyez j'ai reçue je
pense 200 ou 300 fois par différentes
voies du coup bah évidemment que ça
m'intéresse pour pour plein de raisons
d'abord parce que bah ça remet en
question ce que je vous dis dans ma
vidéo sur le tatouage
donc ça peut être intéressant de mettre
un petit peu à jour les informations
et puis ensuite bien sûr le détatouage
voilà on vient d'en parler pendant
quelques minutes là vous comprenez bien
que ça m'intéresse donc je les ai
contactés
j'ai eu un début de réponse donc
normalement si tout va bien d'ici
quelques semaines
j'aurais discuter avec eux pour savoir a
vraiment de quoi de quoi il en retourne
et puis bien évidemment je vous
raconterai tout ça en vidéo
voilà du coup mais vous ai compris vous
me me sentais venir
dtc là c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là j'entends rien d'ici là
oui voilà d'ici là mettez vous bien et
portez vous bien
donc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui bonsoir est ce que c'est possible de
prendre un rendez vous pour une coupe
des cheveux demain